okay let's play some really big guy
sweet harmony 2900 wow
okay let's uh go e4 then
let's say e4 is a good move so
we play good moves against good players
so what should i play here
um i don't know can i play b4 here
actually
i've never thought about it but it kind
of looks reasonable
he goes e5 okay and then we go b5 i
think
the bluff kind of worked
and probably i don't know bishop c4
it is actually a strange position
i don't know how should i i should play
this exactly maybe i go
knight c3
and um yeah okay let's go on s3 and uh
wait for some bishop g4 to take on e5
that's the way we play we play for
cheapos
okay he did not wander
which is bad okay let's just go h3 to
prevent bishop g4 then
and d3
and now we'll have to sort of play it
simple
like castles a495 at some point
yeah he goes bishop e6 which allows many
things including um
including knight g5 for instance i kind
of like knight g5 actually
it's funny that's sometimes in this
situations you have knight takes e4 is
black
and then after dx you have bishop take
c4 and after knight takes c4 you can
play d5
maybe it was not good here exactly
though
okay so he trades now we have this
brilliant d5 square
for the knight
so i guess i guess it should be good for
us
a6 is reasonable so here he's trying to
yeah to come up with some counter play
there and we don't have a 4 8 x b 5
8 x b 5 as um as
the rook is hanging so i have to
have to decide something about the pawn
structure here so it's easier we just
take on a6 and go rogue b1 which i kind
of like
or we just go a4 abcb which i
don't like that much but it's probably
better better option okay let's go e4
and take
still i had some strange feelings that
btx was awesome
it was also quite reasonable
but this way it is obviously much more
standard so i don't um
yeah i mean i don't play with double
pawns if he takes on d5 if i go c takes
and
uh i don't have this problem anymore so
now i guess we just go re1
yeah and now he allows eight xb5
which i think he shouldn't have allowed
actually but maybe we can play set xb5
still
i don't know what's better
yeah this is um this is a strange game
i must say
okay let's go yeah i don't know
let's go eight eggs maybe
yeah so now i mean it was sort of
strange someone have the double
bones um
yeah if i go c takes b5 then a4 is weak
in many ways
and this bishop d8 idea which is uh
which is a nice idea in general would be
even more powerful
after 8xb5 so now i think we should
play it slow somehow so we go queen d3
and now i think we go 91 which i kind of
like so i want to bring the knight to
e3 at some point and then it will
probably jump to f5 on the
he goes queen e6
uh and the point that he wants to take
on f3
therefore i think i go knight h2 and if
it's not a blunder we're actually
threatening c3 trapping
dropping the knight so he will probably
just go back amazon will go 93
and i think we sort of outplayed him
here
yeah knight h5 probably
yeah i don't know d5 or uh maybe this
one
belongs to d5
but where is my increment actually so is
it
yeah it is an increment okay fine
so i could just place history dropping
the knight but i uh
i missed it once but i don't miss it now
so he has to go with five
and it ridiculously works for him yeah
that is unpleasant
so should i take on h6 now yeah okay
whatever let's take and go see takes d4
but now it obviously gets out of uh
gets out of control i mean it could be
still better for white but
i'm not that sure anymore to be honest
okay i think he wanders again
running into g4
after wishes think white is just
kind of winning
yeah so he's trying to bring the rook to
jade
which i think we should survive
yeah maybe bishop before bishop g3
we're also threatening knight f6 check
by the way yeah this should be
just that lost
also i am obviously capable of
messing up pretty much any position
maybe not this one though yeah he
resigns okay thanks for the game
yeah i think we kind of uh we kind of
played
uh we kind of played a very smart
sequence of moves with this knight h2
and also maneuvering
and i think well well played him
outplayed him but then i blundered this
f5 after which
i mean maybe it was still better for
white but we shouldn't have allowed this